No.
Hey, Chris, hey, David.
Hey, Max, how you doing?
Hey, Manish.
I'm doing good.
How about you?
Doing well, thanks for asking.
Singh.
Nice. Hey, Tom.
Hey, guys.
Okay, so what about others? I believe they must be joining in as well.
Hey, Cohen.
Hello, Team! Long time no see. Chris, David, Tom.
Hello!
Oh, it's been so, it's been so long, Kevin, so long, so long.
PH.
So long, yeah, yeah, absolutely.
Good.
Just can't believe.
I know, man. You look, you grow, you grow a beard since the last time I saw you.
See? That's it? Exactly. Last time you saw me I was shaved. Now look at me now.
Yeah.
I was about to say the same thing.
I, you know, that wasn't there, that was exactly, man.
Yeah.
That's an overnight thing for you.
The.
Yeah, you never know, but the AI medical is also in exploring all the possibilities.
Oh, so you're deep fake, Kevin. Got it. Now we know that you, yep, you revealed it all. You revealed it all.
You never know. Oh my god, you just, David just got it.
Look at that.
Thanks.
One Deepak - that's the name.
Yeah.
Kevin Bott.
Yeah, yeah.
I need to make sure the filter is off.
Yeah.
I.
Hi, Ryan.
Hey, Ryan, hey, Bryan.
Hey, everyone, how are you?
At least I can say this to Ryan long time no see, because that is actually true. Playing awesome, Bryan.
Hey, how are you Kevin? I know. I haven't talked to you for a while. How you been?
See, I've been great, Bryan. How about you?
Yeah.
Real good, yep.
Cool, cool. We got a new wallpaper this time. Every time you show up, there's a new wallpaper.
Go on good.
EE.
Yeah, I had to change my old one for something and then I switched it up to something new. So I had Tom's for a while, the, oh, and Christopher's, I think the data center one. I was running for a little bit, but yeah, went to this, so.
Oh, but I really, I mean from my perspective, I love the data center one. It looks amazing.
gives me an excuse for when I don't hear something. I go, what? Sorry, the fans are loud.
Yeah, I'm in the data center. Can't help you.
That's a nice one. Fant a lot. I can't hear you.
Or just disconnect and be like, yeah, the connection's bad in the data center, you know.
Okay.
Yeah, exactly. Too loud.
The connection is bad in the data center, we got different problems.
PH.
What?
Why, why is David so shy? Why is he not switching on his camera?
I'll never tell you. I'll never say.
Yeah.
You know, you know why why I'm asking, David, you know it.
Yes, you know, oh, well, yeah, my big beautiful eyes, I got you, I got you, my big blues.
The magician ever revealed the secrets.
There you go.
Yeah, big blues, that's nice.
You were denied today. You were denied.
Yeah.
Because I'm talking to Kevin Bott right now. You're not the real thing.
That.
Yeah.
Then, let's let's why don't you show up, then I'll switch off my filter.
That's why you try to keep getting us to go to those events so they can fuel your AI revolution so you don't have to work and can be on the beach all day. You're doing better. You're doing better for sure.
Yeah.
Trying, I'm trying, David. We're getting better.
There you go.
Alright, Manish, this will keep on, you know, this is this is how we roll, so why don't you, you know, go ahead and start the show, man? It's your show. I'm just having fun.
Okay.
Yep.
One moment, just bringing it up.
Yeah.
By the way, who are we missing? I know Andrew has the E-white, so...
Bird is also available. I'm not sure if you can join.
Larry's out of office, so he won't join.
Is Lady on vacation?
They're having a big like corporate powwow in Florida. Yep.
They got mad, yeah, they got they got monkey monk meetings in Florida.
Nice. Miami, Florida.
No, I believe it's Orlando.
Orlando, okay, that's cool.
Let the magic happen.
That's right.
One moment, it's acting up.
Give me one quick moment, I believe.
There's something wrong with teams. Yeah, it's something wrong with teams. It's not showing up.
No worries, Manish, take your time.
No pressure.
No pressure. Meanwhile, I was going through my, you know, the YouTube videos and I'm looking at the New York Knicks videos, it's all over the place.
No, it's crazy. I thought, I thought.
That's it, man. After what, 53 years? 53 years? Yeah, so I'm saying that's a big deal, man. When you have a city of millions of people all sharing one, you know, combined happiness, you know, you get you get buses burning.
53 years. 53 years.
Yep.
Agarwal.
I think one of us was there when they won the last one, so.
Absolutely.
Yeah, he's talking.
Kip.
And I, and as as for the record, it were like 5 million people showed up during the parade. I don't know if it's a record.
I don't know about that. That sounds like a lot.
Yeah, 5 million.
It's probably closer to two.
Thank you.
And then keep in mind they had to clean up the day after for two other parades.
Nice. Good luck with that.
Yeah, Manhattan, so it's a city, a city unlike any other.
Drew.
PH.
I believe my screen is visible.
Yeah, we can see it. Yeah, Manish, you can see it.
Yeah, it looks good.
And it is the presentation, not the actual PowerPoint, right? Okay, great. Okay, I welcome you to our monthly business review. Talking about the agenda, we'll be going through the regular one. We'll talk about the highlights. We'll talk about the
Looks good.
Yeah, yeah, we can see it.
KPI is the performance analysis. We'll be going to the end user sentiments, holiday schedule that we have got, and then we'll be going through our AI by design along with the way forward.
Okay, so talking about the highlights, we just got a new engineer selected as Nixon's replacement, Shubhi. She will be starting soon. And Jamie and Shukla continue to provide excellent free support for New Mexico team and Stellan.
Yeah.
is taking care of the RMW account and getting the positive feedbacks from the engineers. And if you talk about the utilization piece, 73% is the billable utilization in the month of May for the entire team with the 84% of ticket result rate.
And if you talk about Ralph and Kyle, they are providing the rock solid support on the weekends.
Okay, so moving on to the next piece, performance. If we talk about the billable utilization, like majority of the engineers, they met their KPIs, starting with Nathan 74% in the month of May, Stellan 89.
Nixon 89 again, talking about Ralph and Kyle, 61 and 55, considering the work over the weekend. So this is the utilization that they have achieved. Talking about for St. Louis, Rico achieved 66%.
which was...
a good performance, but below the target. So he's working on, he's taking care of multiple queues. So I'm sure he will be, like he has shown some improvement over the last few months and this, the graph is going to go up. That's what I can say. Talking about New Mexico, Leah, 67%, Shella, 75.
Jamie clocked 70% and for the Kansas City it was Matthew who achieved 84%.
So any questions in here before I move on to the next page?
Anything you want to add in, maybe Tom, Bryan, Kris, David?
Nope, I'm good.
Vaid.
No, I'm good. Thank you.
Perfect. Moving on to the next one. The next one is the ticket resolve rate. Nathan standing out with 96% of the tickets that he closed. And this is a consistent performance month on month. So I would call him as the ticket muncher. So he's
munching out all the tickets that he's working on. I mean, Nixon and Stellan, they achieve, they also had a good ticket result rate. And again, most of these are the consistent performances that we're looking at. Ralph is at 81%.
Kyle, 74% again, considering that it's a weekend support, so numbers go up and down for him, though he's 74%, so just missed the target by 1% over here. Talking about St. Louis Rico, 94%.
person though his utilization was low, but whatever he's working on, he's closing those tickets. So that's again, a good improvement that we have seen with him. And this is a positive trend that we're looking at. So talking about New Mexico, 85% for Leah.
Shella closed at 72%, considering that Shella is the newest resource in the team, so still maintaining 72%. That is, and that with the second month of working, that's a good performance. Jamie 85, and Matthew is at 87%.
K, so any questions before I move on to next?
Okay, so talking, yeah.
Ohh.
Nope, I'm good. Thanks.
Okay, so talking about the end user sentiments, we've got like this is just the reiteration of the CSAT that we're getting for all these engineers. So Nathan getting good CSAT from the end users. In fact, all of them are getting a positive CSAT few of them.
have comments. I have mentioned a few of them which had the comments in here. There are still apart from these, there are a lot many that have showed up.
Okay, so moving on to the next one, the holiday schedule, the upcoming one is 3rd of July. That is we have, so I like do any of the engineers need to work on 3rd of July? I'm not sure whether it will be the skeleton support that is required or it will be
Like all the offices will be closed. So do you need any of further support or coverage on 3rd of July?
Saint Louis, May.
I'll talk to Rico when we get closer to that, but yeah, sometimes.
Okay.
Definitely not in New York. We're good.
Mhm.
Okay, no worries. So we can always circle back on that one. We have enough time, two weeks in between. So let us know if any support is required. We can look into that part.
Okay, so moving on to the next piece, build IT event that we have. So this is our signature event that is taking place in the month of August from 3rd to 5th. So I believe like we have already like.
All of you might have received the...
The information regarding it, so I...
Sorry.
Is anyone joining Build ITBD from your side? Like maybe Tom, Kris, anyone from your side? Bryan, David, are you coming to Build ITBD?
No.
Hey.
No, sir.
I wish I could.
Nope, that's a Larry question.
Okay, so.
Not Larry and gonna either trust me.
Dharam.
The.
I'm tagging him.
Unless it's free, you ain't gonna.
So, so I don't know, go up, go up to 10 levels of sea level chain we have.
Yeah.
It, it's free. Who said we who said we are charging? It's free, rightly it's free.
I was going to say, I honestly, like, we can get him a ticket. That's not a concern.
There you go.
Okay, I guess Tom's going.
I was gonna say, Tom, Tom, you know that you...
Haha.
Again, I've always, I, I've always said...
You know that Wednesday, Wednesday night, Wednesday night, we're throwing a huge party at the New York Stock Exchange, Florida, Florida New York Stock Exchange.
Yeah.
I used to work, I used to.
Uh-oh.
Ohh, there you go, your old, your old stomping grounds, Tom.
Yeah.
I worked at the New York Stock Exchange for 33 years, brother.
I knew that. That's why I was pointing it out.
And I was on that, I spent a good portion of my life on that floor.
So, uh...
Yeah.
Well, I don't know if you're ever allowed to drink on the job, but now you'd be allowed to have a cocktail or two while there.
Would be nice.
No, we used to have our Christmas parties down there too, actually, so it was great. Yeah.
Ohh, very nice, very nice.
Yeah, I'll tag Larry about it again.
Listen, I love to go. I like Jersey City. I used to work in Jersey City too, so I don't have a problem with that.
The events genuinely worthwhile, and I've been to hundreds of these things, but nothing like this. We keep the group intentionally smaller so that it can be focused. You can actually have worthwhile and meaningful conversations. The biggest sales pitch you're going to get is us
I agree.
on these calls, try to get you there, and then once you're there, we, it's not a sales pitch, right? So once you're there, it's just sessions and collaboration. So yeah, I'll talk to Larry and see what he will.
If Larry allows it, I would love to attend.
Awesome. Awesome. Thank you.
Maybe he'll come too.
Yeah.
Okay, so moving on to the AI by design. So that is again part of our build IT event as well. So there will be sessions around AI, AI, AI, AI. That's something that everyone is talking about and that will be part of our build IT event as well. Okay, so talking about team GPS, we already know about this software, our homegrown software.
that like there is a QR code in here in case any information is required. You can either fill out, scan this code or let us know and we can arrange a call for you to go through all the questions regarding it.
Okay, so talking about way forward, as we talked about, Shubhi has replaced Nixon. So she will be going through her training for like the, I would say the transition training that she'll be going through. Then we will be
focusing on meeting our KPIs, that's the benchmark scores that we work on. So we stay focused on that and we will be ensuring that we are able to meet all your expectations and provide any kind of support that is required for our partnership to grow.
Okay, so that brings us to the end of our presentation. I thank you for your time for this presentation. I'll stop sharing my screen. And any questions, anything anyone wants to add in over here? Maybe I'll start with Kris.
You're the first person on my screen. I'll start with you. Anything you want to talk in.
No, nothing out of the ordinary. The guys are doing a good job. I know I worked with you earlier and we closed out the SIP just for the rest of the group here. We closed out the SIP for Nathan. His communication has improved over the last month or two. So he's doing a lot better with that. And we'll just look forward to seeing his continued growth.
Yeah.
It's really about it.
Thank you, Kris. David, anything from your side?
Not really. I mean, Kyle and Ralph are doing great per usual. I know Ralph is out today. So yeah, nothing but positive feedback regarding both. No issues from clients. They're still doing great.
Thank you, Tom.
What he said.
He said that.
I, I concur with David said. I got, I got, I don't have any feedback. It's all positive, all good stuff. Everybody's everybody's doing well, so...
He concurs. The gentleman concurs.
Nice.
Yeah.
Nice. Bryan, you are next.
Yeah, Rico's been great. Like you guys have tracked, he's improving. We've been kind of following up with him more, just kind of, you know, not really necessarily pushing him, but just kind of staying up to date with him. And he's doing a great job. And we've also been having him kind of work in the California region as well, too, to where he's just, he gets more opportunity to close tickets. So I think that's where we're seeing that improvements. He's just having.
More to to work on, so yep, he's been doing great.
Nice, nice. That's really good to know. Talking about like, oh, Cohen, anything you want to add in?
Questions?
Manish, your first.
Call running the show, so you did well, so thank you so much for that. Next time I won't show up, so...
Thank you.
Yeah.
No questions for my friend. Thanks A lot. So all the credit goes to Manish. He has been working with the team and I see that collaboration and I'm just taking the back step. So he's doing well. Thanks a lot, Manish. That's all.
Thank you, Evan. Ayra, before I move on to Andrew and Vishal, anything from your side?
We're all good. Thank you, Manish.
Welcome. Andrea, anything from your side?
Yeah, probably with Shell's utilization. Currently it's at 75. So Ayra and I is going to work with her. I know she's pretty new. So I would assume that she is acclimating still, but we still wanted to make sure that she hits that 80% standard that we wanted for the utilization. So we're going to work on that.
So hopefully next time that we meet, it's going to be up to par. Yeah, that's pretty much it for me. Thank you.
Welcome, Andrew. Uh, Vishal, over to you.
Thank you so much, Max. I have my...
P was with me that I've connected with Tom and Team this afternoon. So I have a plan in place that I'm going to work. That is a priority. Rest time, I'm good. Thank you for running this call. Thank you so much, Max. And again, thank you so much, Tom and Team, for your time this afternoon. I appreciate that.
Plus, anytime.
Yep.
Thank you, Vishal. Thank you, Jim. Thank you for your time today. We'll catch up next time. Have a great day ahead.
All right, thanks, guys.
I have a good one, all. Bye. Bye.
Take care, buddy.
Thank you, De. Thanks, everyone. Bye.
Thank you.
Bye.